Welcome to our second drink of Crime Aid. We have some fantastic behind-the-scenes details from the writer of this episode, Charlie Grandy. And Jen Salada also shares about directing this episode. It was her first time directing on The Office. What a debut for her. I know. It's got so many classic moments. So many.
欢迎来到我们的第二杯“犯罪援助”。我们从本集编剧查理·格兰迪那里得到了一些精彩的幕后细节。珍·萨拉达也分享了执导这一集的经历。这是她第一次执导《办公室》。对她来说，这真是个了不起的处女作。我知道。这一集有太多经典时刻了。太多了。
Okay, let's start with the fan favorite moment from Lisa R and Plumas Lake, California, and Melanie D. from Austin, Texas. It's when Michael explains what Crime Aid stands for. Melanie said, ladies, when Michael says that crime aid means crime reduces innocence makes everyone angry, I declare, I laugh every time. I'm curious if there were any alts for that. Well, we did share that the writer Charlie Grandy came up with that acronym by himself, but I went to the candy bag alts because I was curious and I went to the original table draft of the script to see if there were any other versions. And Melanie, Charlie nailed it from the very beginning. Crime reduces innocence makes everyone angry, I declare, was in all of the early
好的，让我们从来自加利福尼亚州普卢马斯湖的丽莎·R和来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的梅兰妮·D最喜欢的粉丝时刻开始。那是迈克尔解释“犯罪援助”（Crime Aid）代表什么的时候。梅兰妮说，女士们，当迈克尔说“犯罪援助”意味着“犯罪减少了无辜，让每个人都生气，我宣布”时，我每次都笑得不行。我很好奇当时有没有备选台词。嗯，我们确实分享过编剧查理·格兰迪是自己想出这个缩写词的，但我去看了糖果袋里的备选台词，因为我很好奇，我还去看了剧本的原始草稿，看看有没有其他版本。梅兰妮，查理从一开始就做到了完美。“犯罪减少了无辜，让每个人都生气，我宣布”出现在所有早期的
drafts of the scripts, no alts needed when something is that funny. I mean, every time you just said it, it made me laugh out loud. I know. It's so ridiculous. I'm really tickled. Our next fan favorite moment comes from Cecilia W. in Shawnee, Kansas, who says, my favorite scene in Crime Aid is when Darrell says that Michael gave him a list of his favorite Bruce Springsteen songs, and then three of them were from Huey Lewis in the news. I have a playlist of songs featured on the show, and I laughed so hard thinking of the scene whenever the Huey Lewis songs come on. That is such a great idea to make a playlist of all the songs that were on The Office.
剧本草稿中，当东西已经这么好笑时，根本不需要备选。我是说，每次你只要说出来，我就忍不住大笑。我知道。太荒谬了。我真的被逗乐了。下一位粉丝最喜欢的时刻来自堪萨斯州肖尼的塞西莉亚·W，她说，我在“犯罪援助”中最喜欢的场景是达里尔说迈克尔给了他一份他最喜欢的布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀歌曲清单，结果其中三首是休伊·刘易斯与新闻乐队的歌。我有一个节目中出现过的歌曲播放列表，每当休伊·刘易斯的歌响起时，想到那个场景，我就笑得不行。制作一个《办公室》中所有歌曲的播放列表真是个好主意。
Yeah. And then you can, like, think about the episode they were in. That's very fun. Cecilia, I love that. All right, we did have a moment that got a fan mail flurry, and that was the scenes. between Dwight and Phyllis. McKella L. from Peoria, Arizona. Love that storyline.
是的。然后你可以回想它们出现在哪一集里。那很有趣。塞西莉亚，我喜欢这个。好了，我们确实有一个引起粉丝来信狂潮的时刻，那就是德怀特和菲利斯之间的场景。来自亚利桑那州皮奥里亚的麦凯拉·L。很喜欢那个故事情节。
So did Christine R. from East Grand Rapids, Michigan. She said, I loved when Phyllis told Dwight, I think we all deserve someone who wants to be with us. It's just so sweet. And So Jan J. from South Korea, but they let us know they now live in Germany. So Jan said, Hello, ladies, can you please talk more about that moment between Dwight and Phyllis?
克里斯汀·R（来自密歇根州东大急流城）也一样。她说，我喜欢菲利斯告诉德怀特“我想我们都值得拥有一个想和我们在一起的人”的时候。真是太甜了。还有来自韩国的索珍·J，但他们告诉我们现在住在德国。所以索珍说，你好，女士们，你们能多谈谈德怀特和菲利斯之间的那个时刻吗？
I know the office is a sitcom, but Rain and Phyllis is acting, like how they portrayed an emotional moment where Dwight and Phyllis are both so hurt, was so powerful that I was awestruck. Well, So Jan, we also love this scene. We describe it in our breakdown, but we didn't play it, and I really think we should hear it. Listen, she ignored my ultimatum. Now what?
我知道《办公室》是一部情景喜剧，但雷恩和菲利斯的表演，他们表现出的那种情感时刻，德怀特和菲利斯都受到了伤害，这太有感染力了，让我感到敬畏。嗯，索珍，我们也喜欢这个场景。我们在解析中描述过它，但我们没有播放它，我真的觉得我们应该听听。听着，她无视了我的最后通牒。现在怎么办？
Now you move on. Okay, fine. I've moved on. Now, how do I get her back? Well, Dwight, I don't think you do. I think you've got your answer. Wait, that's it? That's your advice?
现在你该继续前进了。好吧，没问题。我已经前进了。现在，我该怎么把她追回来？嗯，德怀特，我不认为你能做到。我想你已经得到答案了。等等，就这样？这就是你的建议？
I thought you had some kind of big master. plan. Well, I just think we all deserve to be with someone who wants to be with us. Oh, I get it. You're trying to secure your place as head of the party planning committee. You're just being selfish. And you slap like a girl. I mean, it's, it's one of those scenes that happens on the show sometimes where you're expecting it to end as a joke or a comedic moment, but it doesn't. It's heavy. It's heavy. It's more dramatic. It is more dramatic. And it's always done so well by our writers where they set it up in a joke way.
我以为你有什么宏大的主计划。嗯，我只是认为我们都值得和想与我们在一起的人在一起。哦，我明白了。你是在试图巩固你作为派对策划委员会负责人的地位。你只是自私。而且你打人像个女孩。我是说，这是剧中偶尔会出现的场景之一，你以为它会以笑话或喜剧时刻结束，但并没有。它很沉重。它很沉重。它更具戏剧性。确实更具戏剧性。而且我们的编剧总是处理得很好，他们用一种开玩笑的方式来铺垫。
And that's what fools you. It's like he gets her to go to the parking lot to have this conversation by telling her she has a flat tire. Right. And she's actually made it a flat tire as well. Yeah. And she's like, you could have just said you wanted to talk. Yeah. Like we didn't have to do this.
这就是让你上当的地方。就像他告诉她车胎瘪了，让她去停车场进行这次谈话一样。对。而且她实际上也确实让车胎瘪了。是的。她说，你本可以直接说你想谈谈的。是的，我们不必非得这样做。
And then it gets dramatic. And then you see Dwight's heartbreak. And then she's actually telling him things that are important. Like you've got to let it go. Yeah. Yeah, and it's not a joke. It's not a joke. Oh, well, listen, thank you everyone who wrote in.
然后它变得戏剧化了。然后你看到了德怀特的心碎。然后她实际上在告诉他一些重要的事情。比如你必须放手。是的。是的，这不是个笑话。这不是个笑话。哦，好吧，听着，谢谢所有写信来的人。
You can head over to OfficeLadies.com and submit your favorite moments for our upcoming second drinks. And now here is our second drink of Crime Aid. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were
你可以前往 OfficeLadies.com 提交你最喜欢的时刻，供我们即将到来的“第二杯”节目使用。现在，这是我们的第二杯“犯罪援助”。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
There can tell you. We're the office ladies. Oh, everybody. Hi, you guys. I have some big news that I want to share with you, Angela. What? Remember when we talked about my long crotch pants. How could I forget?
我们是办公室女士。哦，大家好。嘿，伙计们。我有一个大新闻想和你分享，安吉拉。什么？还记得我们谈论我的长裆裤吗？我怎么会忘呢？
Long crotch. I had them altered. Oh, you had your crotch altered. Well, I had the waist altered. Oh, okay. I took an inch out of the back of the waist. And now they fit your crotch right? Yep, I'm wearing them today.
长裆。我把它们改了。哦，你改了你的裆部。嗯，我改了腰部。哦，好吧。我从腰部后面缩了一英寸。现在它们适合你的裆部了吗？是的，我今天穿着它们。
I wanted to show you. She got the crotch right. She got the crotch right. That's right. Now it fits you right in the butt, too. It does. Because before you had saggy bottom and long crotch. I know. But now I fixed it.
我想给你看看。她把裆部改对了。她把裆部改对了。没错。现在它也正好贴合你的臀部了。确实。因为之前你的屁股下垂，裆部又长。我知道。但我现在修好了。
And since I brought the problem to the pod, I thought I'd bring the solution to the pod. I'm here for it. Well, we have a very fun episode today. It is Crime Aid, Season 5, Episode 5, written by Charlie Grandi and directed by Jen Salada. Here's your summary. Pam is working at corporate in New York City to help pay for her life at Ardette. school. Holly and Michael take their relationship to the next level, resulting in a burglary at the office. Michael hosts an auction to recoup the valuables lost, and Dwight turns to Phyllis for advice on how to
既然我把这个问题带到了播客上，我想我也应该把解决方案带到播客上。我支持这一点。嗯，我们今天有一集非常有趣的节目。这是《犯罪援助》，第五季第五集，由查理·格兰迪编剧，珍·萨拉达执导。这是你的摘要。帕姆在纽约市的总部工作，以帮助支付她在艺术学校的生活费。霍莉和迈克尔将他们的关系提升到了一个新的水平，导致办公室发生了入室盗窃。迈克尔举办了一场拍卖会来收回丢失的贵重物品，德怀特向菲利斯寻求关于如何
win Angela back. I loved everything Dwight and Phyllis. What a great combo. That's the thing the writers did. They like to mix it up. I was here for it. I absolutely loved it as well. That moves me in to Fast fact number one. Do it. New writer alert. New writer alert. Charlie Grandy. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. It's another new writer alert. So before working on the office, Charlie was a stand-up comedian, and he wrote for The Daily Show with John Stewart and Saturday Night Live. He's super funny. Super funny. After the office, he went on to write for the Mindy Project, and Angela, Charlie said that one of the main inspirations for this episode was to highlight Phyllis. Charlie, you did it and I love that you love Phyllis.
赢回安吉拉的建议。我喜欢德怀特和菲利斯的一切。真是绝配。这就是编剧们所做的事情。他们喜欢把事情混合起来。我支持这一点。我也绝对喜欢。这让我进入了第一个速记事实。来吧。新编剧警报。新编剧警报。查理·格兰迪。叮叮叮叮叮叮。又是新编剧警报。所以在为《办公室》工作之前，查理是一名脱口秀喜剧演员，他为乔恩·斯图尔特的《每日秀》和《周六夜现场》写过稿。他超级有趣。超级有趣。在《办公室》之后，他继续为《明迪烦事多》写稿，安吉拉，查理说这一集的主要灵感之一是突出菲利斯。查理，你做到了，我喜欢你喜欢菲利斯这一点。
Yeah. He said this was one of those situations where they wanted to do a storyline with an unusual pairing. Remember they used to just put people's names on cards and pair them up? This was Dwight Phyllis. I love it. This is what happens when you put the Dwight and Phyllis cards together. You know what card never came together? What? Jim Angela. You're so right. You're so right. Fast fact number two, this is the first episode that Jen Salada directed. Oh, Jen! That's right.
是的。他说这是他们想要做一个不寻常配对的故事情节的情况之一。还记得他们过去常把人们的名字写在卡片上并把他们配对吗？这就是德怀特和菲利斯。我喜欢它。这就是当你把德怀特和菲利斯的卡片放在一起时会发生的事情。你知道什么卡片从来没有放在一起过吗？什么？吉姆和安吉拉。你说得太对了。你说得太对了。第二个速记事实，这是珍·萨拉达执导的第一集。哦，珍！没错。
Yeah. I mean, guys, it was so much fun to have Jen on set. She was such a laugher. She was such a blast. She was also one of the showrunners this season with Paul Lieberstein. She'd been on the show for a while. And I don't know if you remember, but during beach games, she talked about how Harold Ramis really encouraged her to direct one day. Yeah. And this was kind of the... That moment.
是的。我是说，伙计们，有珍在片场真是太有趣了。她真是个爱笑的人。她真是个开心果。她也是这一季与保罗·利伯斯坦一起的剧集主管之一。她在节目中待了一段时间了。我不知道你是否还记得，但在“海滩游戏”期间，她谈到了哈罗德·雷米斯是如何真正鼓励她有一天去执导的。是的。这就是那种……那个时刻。
Yeah. This was where it led. So we reached out to Jen and we have some really fun stuff to sprinkle through the episode. I asked her specifically, okay, what was it like directing your first episode? And she said the thing that like really stressed her out the most was that she thought directors had to have all the answers. She was really worried that someone would ask her a question about a prop or how to set up a scene and that she wouldn't know. And she said, someone gave her the advice to just kind of like fake it till you make it sort of thing. But Jen was like, I can't. I can't fake it.
是的。这就是它引导的方向。所以我们联系了珍，我们有一些非常有趣的东西可以在这一集中穿插。我特别问她，执导你的第一集是什么感觉？她说让她压力最大的事情是她认为导演必须拥有所有的答案。她非常担心有人会问她关于道具或如何布置场景的问题，而她却不知道。她说，有人给了她一个建议，就是那种“假装直到你成功”的方法。但珍说，我不能。我不能假装。
If I don't know something, I'm going to shout out, I don't know. Well, Jen wears every emotion across her face, right? You know how Jen feels about something. Well, I have to say, I really respect a person who says I don't know. I do too. I don't need fake it till you make it. I would much rather just know truly how someone's feeling. I don't need like the whatever thing, the filter people put on.
如果我不知道某件事，我会大声说出来，我不知道。嗯，珍的脸上写满了每一种情绪，对吧？你知道珍对某件事的感觉。嗯，我不得不说，我真的很尊重一个说“我不知道”的人。我也一样。我不需要“假装直到你成功”。我宁愿真正知道某人的感受。我不需要那种人们戴上的过滤器。
I agree. Well, she also said that Jeff Blitz gave her the advice. Don't worry if you don't sleep the night before your first day of shooting. No director sleeps the night before and your adrenaline will kick in. And she said that was absolutely true. She did not sleep. And her adrenaline did kick in. So she was good.
我同意。嗯，她还说杰夫·布里茨给了她建议。不要担心你在拍摄第一天前晚上睡不着觉。没有导演会在前一天晚上睡觉，你的肾上腺素会发挥作用。她说那是绝对正确的。她确实没睡。她的肾上腺素确实发挥了作用。所以她很好。
I bet. I can't sleep like before. or a big day ever. I'm like up all through the night. I know. That happens to me as an actor the night before my first day on a new project especially. I'm so nervous. The day before a big trip, I'm always like, okay, did I pack my charger? Got it. Underwear, I don't know. Did it pack underwear? I don't know. I don't know. Oh my cat. I got to get up. I can go look. I can't. I can't. I can't like sleep the night before anything big. All right. Are you ready for fast fact number three? Yes. Roy is back. Oh, yes, he is.
我敢打赌。我从来没能在重要日子前睡着。我整晚都醒着。我知道。作为一名演员，在进入新项目的第一天前晚上，我也会这样。我太紧张了。大旅行的前一天，我总是想，好吧，我带充电器了吗？带了。内衣，我不知道。我带内衣了吗？我不知道。我不知道。哦，我的猫。我得起床。我可以去看看。我不能。我不能。我不能在任何大事前一晚睡觉。好了。你准备好迎接第三个速记事实了吗？是的。罗伊回来了。哦，是的，他回来了。
He comes back in this episode, and it's a huge surprise. It's so well done. The writers said they were always looking for ways to bring David back. Well, I hadn't seen this episode in a long time, and when I watched it and he walked in, I was like, oh, God, Roy's here. And now he's with Jim. Oh, no, no, no. Like, I completely forgot. I have a show Bible summary of Roy Anderson.
他在这集中回来了，这是一个巨大的惊喜。做得太好了。编剧们说他们一直在寻找让大卫回来的方法。嗯，我很久没看这一集了，当我观看它，他走进来时，我想，哦，天哪，罗伊在这里。现在他和吉姆在一起。哦，不，不，不。就像，我完全忘了。我有一个罗伊·安德森的节目圣经摘要。
Remember, we never did a show Bible goodbye for him, so I thought maybe let's remember Roy since we're going to see him this week. Let's do it. Roy Anderson worked in the warehouse. At Dundermifflin, he was engaged to Pam for three years. They went to high school together. He was on the football team, and he hoped they would go to Mexico for their honeymoon.
记住，我们从来没有为他做过节目圣经告别，所以我想也许让我们记住罗伊，因为我们这周要见到他。让我们做吧。罗伊·安德森在仓库工作。在邓德·米夫林，他与帕姆订婚了三年。他们一起上了高中。他是足球队的，他希望他们能去墨西哥度蜜月。
He has wave runners that he bought with his brother, which they eventually sold at a loss. He has a truck. He would carpool to work with Pam. He thinks Angelo's kind of hot. He plays fantasy football and he is eventually fired after he tries to attack Jim. He apologizes to Pam and moves on until this episode, when he runs into Jim at a bar, and it is revealed he's been working at Vitamin World.
他有和他兄弟一起买的水上摩托，他们最终亏本卖掉了。他有一辆卡车。他会和帕姆拼车上班。他觉得安吉拉有点性感。他玩梦幻足球，在试图攻击吉姆后最终被解雇。他向帕姆道歉并继续前进，直到这一集，他在酒吧遇到吉姆，并透露他一直在维生素世界工作。
Vitamin Shop is what his shirt said. It did? I thought it said Vitamin World. It said vitamin Shoppy, S-H-O-P-P-E. Hmm, I'm going to revisit that, I guess. I'll take another look at his shirt, although I do believe you. Well, now I'm having that moment, like, wait, I'm pretty sure it's a vitamin shop. Oh, dear. Oh, Lord.
他的衬衫上写的是维生素商店。是吗？我以为写的是维生素世界。写的是维生素商店，S-H-O-P-P-E。嗯，我想我会重新审视一下，我想。我会再看一眼他的衬衫，虽然我相信你。嗯，现在我有那种感觉，就像，等等，我很确定它是维生素商店。哦，亲爱的。哦，天哪。
Time code. We need a time coat. Well, lady, that's all I got. I've got some fun tidbits. There was good deleted scenes for this one. All right. Well, should we take a break and then we'll get to it? Let's get to it.
时间码。我们需要一个时间码。嗯，女士，这就是我所有的了。我有一些有趣的花絮。这一集有很好的删减场景。好吧。嗯，我们应该休息一下，然后我们再来讨论吗？让我们开始吧。
I like it. We are back, and Pam is working in an office. What's going on? Why isn't she in art school? I'm confused. It looks a lot like a paper company. Well, that's because it is. It is Dunder Mifflin corporate.
我喜欢。我们回来了，帕姆在办公室工作。发生了什么？她为什么不在艺术学校？我很困惑。它看起来很像一家造纸公司。嗯，那是因为它确实是。它是邓德·米夫林总部。
Mm-hmm. She gets a phone call. It's Michael. Of course it's Michael, because now he knows where she is. All the time. All the time. Well, he knows how to reach her part of the time, at least. There was a missing scene in this little runner of Pam working in New York.
嗯哼。她接到了一个电话。是迈克尔。当然是迈克尔，因为现在他知道她在哪里了。一直都知道。一直都知道。嗯，他至少知道在部分时间如何联系她。帕姆在纽约工作的这个小片段里有一个缺失的场景。
At one point, Michael's going to call her and ask her. for a slice of pizza. She's like Michael. And she's like, Michael, if I get you a slice of pizza, we stop calling, basically. And then the next scene is Michael opening up like a FedEx package and there's one slice of pizza, not wrapped in anything, like loose. And he starts eating it and it's sort of come apart in the packaging. And he's so happy because he got his New York slice from Pam.
有一次，迈克尔要打电话给她，向她要一片披萨。她说，迈克尔。她说，迈克尔，如果我给你一片披萨，我们就停止打电话，基本上。然后下一个场景是迈克尔打开一个像联邦快递的包裹，里面有一片披萨，没有用任何东西包裹，就像散装的。他开始吃它，它在包装里有点散开了。他非常高兴，因为他从帕姆那里得到了他的纽约披萨。
I mean, that is so gross. How long did it take to get there? But I love the idea that Pam sort of passively aggressively or whatever. I don't know, mailed Michael a slice of pizza. And he was delighted. It was deleted, unfortunately. Unfortunately, and poor Steve had to eat that pizza quite a bit. And he had huge bites of it.
我是说，那太恶心了。到那里花了多长时间？但我喜欢帕姆有点被动攻击性或者什么的，我不知道，给迈克尔寄了一片披萨的想法。他很高兴。不幸的是，它被删除了。不幸的是，可怜的史蒂夫不得不吃那片披萨好几次。他咬了很大一口。
Like his cheeks were all full of pizza. Well, now we move into the episode and Michael and Holly arrived to work. They are glowing. Well, they've been super flirty. They've had two dates. And tonight, they're going to go out. And it's going to be their third date. Yeah.
就像他的脸颊里塞满了披萨。嗯，现在我们进入这一集，迈克尔和霍莉到达工作地点。他们容光焕发。嗯，他们一直非常调情。他们已经约会两次了。今晚，他们要出去。这将是他们的第三次约会。是的。
And Michael says, in America, the third date is usually when you have sex. And he hopes Holly agrees with that. If she starts having sex with me, I'll know for sure is what he says. Yeah. So, lady, Michael's whole thing where he's talking about the third date is when you have sex, I was intrigued because I remember the show Sex in the City. Well, yeah. Do you remember that?
迈克尔说，在美国，第三次约会通常是发生性关系的时候。他希望霍莉同意这一点。如果她开始和我发生性关系，我就能确定了，他是这么说的。是的。所以，女士，迈克尔谈论第三次约会是发生性关系的时候，我很感兴趣，因为我记得《欲望都市》这部剧。嗯，是的。你还记得吗？
Of course. So in Sex in the City, there's this scene where Charlotte gives a big speech to the group of friends where she says she never has sex until the third date no matter what. This is her rule. Okay. There was actually a book called The Rules that women were supposed to follow in order to like nab a man. I remember that book. Remember the rule? Oh, God.
当然。所以在《欲望都市》中，有这样一个场景，夏洛特对一群朋友发表了长篇大论，她说无论如何，她从不在第三次约会前发生性关系。这是她的规则。好的。实际上有一本书叫《规则》，女性应该遵循这些规则来“捕获”一个男人。我记得那本书。还记得那个规则吗？哦，天哪。
Right? I know. So crazy. So that was kind of, I think, the inspiration for this idea that you wait till the third date. And doesn't Michael love sex in the city? He does love sex in the city. So I think that's what he is quoting Charlotte. Yeah, he's quoting Charlotte.
对吧？我知道。太疯狂了。所以我认为，这大概就是这个想法的灵感来源，即你等到第三次约会。迈克尔不是喜欢《欲望都市》吗？他确实喜欢《欲望都市》。所以我认为他是在引用夏洛特的话。是的，他是在引用夏洛特。
Except he's twisted it. Yeah, to America. Charlotte is like, I never have sex to the third date. And Michael is like, I get laid on the third date. Yeah. That's how he heard that. Well, it got me curious. I Googled, is there an ideal amount of time to date before sex?
除了他把它扭曲了。是的，扭曲到了美国。夏洛特说，我从不在第三次约会前发生性关系。而迈克尔说，我在第三次约会时上床。是的。他是那样听到的。嗯，这让我很好奇。我谷歌了一下，约会多久发生性关系是理想的？
Okay, this is what's so funny is that I started to look this up and I was like, I just have a feeling Jenna's going to look this up. I looked it up. Are you ready for what I found? Oh, no. Go. It was super interesting. It was similar to our sex timer conversation.
好的，这太搞笑了，我开始查这个，我想，我只是有种感觉珍娜会查这个。我查了。你准备好迎接我的发现了吗？哦，不。说吧。这超级有趣。它类似于我们的性计时器对话。
There was a Groupon survey of 2,000 adults in the United States. Wait, Groupon? Groupon. Like what you sign up for to get, like, better tickets to Disneyland? Like, Groupon? Yeah. I was so confused why Groupon was asking people this question. Okay.
有一个 Groupon 对美国 2000 名成年人的调查。等等，Groupon？Groupon。就像你注册为了获得更好的迪士尼乐园门票的那种？像 Groupon？是的。我很困惑为什么 Groupon 会问人们这个问题。好的。
But it's their survey. They wanted to know how long people waited to have sex with a new partner. Now, I'm just saying, if your Groupon app sent you this question, would you answer it? I would not answer. I'd be like, Groupon, this is not your business. Groupon, stay in your lane. Yeah. Well, here's their result.
但这是他们的调查。他们想知道人们等待多久才与新伴侣发生性关系。现在，我只是说，如果你的 Groupon 应用程序给你发了这个问题，你会回答吗？我不会回答。我会说，Groupon，这不是你的事。Groupon，管好你自己的事。是的。嗯，这是他们的结果。
The average answer was eight dates with women waiting nine and men waiting five. They also found that men were nine times more likely to be okay with having sex on the first date. You think? All right. Have a new study. Here's the other study. This one feels a little bit more legit. Oh, it's not Groupon.
平均答案是八次约会，女性等待九次，男性等待五次。他们还发现，男性在第一次约会时发生性关系的可能性是女性的九倍。你觉得呢？好的。有一个新研究。这是另一个研究。这个感觉稍微更合法一点。哦，它不是 Groupon。
It's not Groupon. You don't get free steak if like eight of you sign up. What other surveys has Groupon been having? Therapists of America. I log on to Groupon. Oh, my gosh. All right. This one is from the Journal of Sex Research.
它不是 Groupon。如果你有八个人注册，你不会得到免费牛排。Groupon 还进行过什么调查？美国治疗师。我登录 Groupon。哦，天哪。好的。这个来自《性研究杂志》。
Sounds a little bit more official. No offense, Groupon. Also, maybe made up. But they analyzed nearly 11,000 unmarried adults who were in serious or steady relationships. Okay. They asked them, at what point in your relationship did you have sex? 51% weighted a few. weeks.
听起来稍微更官方一点。没有冒犯的意思，Groupon。另外，也许是编造的。但他们分析了近 11,000 名处于认真或稳定关系中的未婚成年人。好的。他们问他们，你在关系的哪个阶段发生了性关系？51% 等待了几周。
38% had sex either on the first date or within two weeks. 11% had sex before their first date. What? How do you do that? I don't know. Like they had sex and then they started dating. Oh, my gosh. Yeah.
38% 在第一次约会或两周内发生了性关系。11% 在第一次约会前就发生了性关系。什么？你怎么做到的？我不知道。就像他们发生了性关系，然后他们开始约会。哦，天哪。是的。
So this isn't exactly saying number of dates, but more like period of time. Okay. They also found that the timing of people's first sexual encounter did not impact their feelings about the relationship in the long run in a meaningful way. So everybody was happy whether they banged before their first date or three weeks later. That book the rules on how to nab your man, that would just throw their theories out the window. Yeah, that's right. Journal of Sex Research.
所以这并不完全是指约会次数，而是指一段时间。好的。他们还发现，人们第一次性接触的时间对他们长期对这段关系的感受没有产生有意义的影响。所以每个人都很开心，无论他们是在第一次约会前还是三周后发生性关系。那本关于如何捕获男人的《规则》书，会把他们的理论扔出窗外。是的，没错。《性研究杂志》。
There was one thing. They said that the people who had sex earlier tended to be slightly less satisfied now in their relationship. Oh, so there was nothing to like, look forward to? Well, that was one of their theories. One of the theories was that since they'd been having sex longer, you know, that early sex was maybe more exciting. And since they'd been at it for a bit longer, since they started earlier, maybe it's lost its shine. I don't know. Everything I read, Ang, said, the best thing you can do is figure out what sex means to you. If sex means physical pleasure, then find someone who agrees if sex means,
有一件事。他们说那些更早发生性关系的人现在在他们的关系中往往稍微不那么满意。哦，所以没有什么值得期待的了？嗯，那是他们的理论之一。其中一个理论是，因为他们发生性关系的时间更长，你知道，早期的性行为可能更令人兴奋。而且因为他们开始得更早，所以他们已经进行了更长时间，也许它失去了光彩。我不知道。我读到的所有东西，安吉，都说，你能做的最好的事情就是弄清楚性对你意味着什么。如果性意味着身体愉悦，那么找到一个同意的人；如果性意味着，
I'm in a committed relationship. Find a partner that agrees. And then you'll have like a really good sexual encounter. That was the advice. Well, Jenna, at the end of all of your research, I have found nuggets from Groupon and the Sex Journal people. What? Journal of Sex Research.
我处于一段忠诚的关系中。找到一个同意的伴侣。然后你就会有一次非常好的性接触。这就是建议。嗯，珍娜，在你所有的研究结束时，我从 Groupon 和性杂志的人那里找到了金块。什么？《性研究杂志》。
Thank you. All good nuggets there. Yeah. Well, listen, while Michael was obsessed with the idea that he might get to have sex tonight, Andy is passing out save the date cards. Andy is excited because he's getting married. He's very excited. He's calling everyone like D-Money, J-Money. At 2 minutes 44 seconds, Dwight opens this invitation. He's clearly concerned that there's a save-the-date. When he opens the envelope, all this confetti comes out. I know. And Rain's reaction is Dwight to it. It was so funny. But that is
谢谢。那里有很多好金块。是的。嗯，听着，当迈克尔沉迷于他今晚可能会发生性关系的想法时，安迪正在分发“保存日期”卡片。安迪很兴奋，因为他要结婚了。他非常兴奋。他称呼每个人为“D-Money”、“J-Money”。在 2 分 44 秒时，德怀特打开了这张请柬。他显然很担心有一个“保存日期”。当他打开信封时，所有的五彩纸屑都出来了。我知道。雷恩的反应是德怀特式的。太搞笑了。但那是
My husband's reaction to it. We were invited to a baby shower and we open the envelope. Now, listen, I'm expecting the confetti and some wedding invitations now. It's become a thing, right? You open the envelope and little wedding bells and things come out of it. I was not expecting confetti out of a baby shower. We opened the envelope. And my husband doesn't open anything gently, so we kind of tore into the envelope.
我丈夫的反应。我们被邀请参加一个婴儿洗礼，我们打开信封。现在，听着，我现在期待着五彩纸屑和一些婚礼请柬。这已经成为一种习惯了，对吧？你打开信封，小婚礼钟和东西从里面出来。我没料到婴儿洗礼会有五彩纸屑。我们打开信封。我丈夫从来不温柔地打开任何东西，所以我们有点撕开了信封。
And all these little bitty baby bottles and baby carriages and little things just like flew up in the air. And my husband was like, why do they do that? I'm with Josh. Welcome to my wedding as I make a mess on your floor. I mean, I'm already I'm annoyed by your wedding or your baby shower. It cracked me up. You know what I mean? Don't mess up my house while you invite me to something. Don't mess up my area with your festivities. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. I'm on the fence about it. Part of me thought it was fun. And the other part was like, oh, no, I got to clean that up. Yeah. I always lean toward I have to clean it up. Well, we're about to have a little bit of what I call break in the wall in the break room. Talk to me about it. Are you confused? Slightly. Three minutes, three seconds. While Dwight is
所有这些小小的婴儿奶瓶和婴儿车以及小东西就像飞到了空中。我丈夫说，他们为什么要那样做？我支持乔什。欢迎来到我的婚礼，因为我在你的地板上制造了一团糟。我是说，我已经对你的婚礼或婴儿洗礼感到恼火了。它让我笑了起来。你知道我的意思吗？不要在邀请我参加某事时弄乱我的房子。不要用你的庆祝活动弄乱我的区域。是的。我不知道。我不知道。我对此持观望态度。我的一部分认为这很有趣。另一部分觉得，哦，不，我得清理它。是的。我总是倾向于我必须清理它。嗯，我们即将有一点我称之为休息室里的“破墙”。跟我谈谈。你困惑吗？稍微。三分钟，三秒。当德怀特正在
whittling a knife with a knife. While Dwight is whittling a knife with a knife, Phyllis wants to know if he's okay. Does he want to talk about it? And she looks right at camera. She goes, you know, I know. You know they know. Phyllis, sassy Phyllis, breaking that fourth wall and bringing the camera crew into it. Yeah. And this is the beginning of that delicious Dwight Phyllis runner. Yes. That is going to play out so beautifully.
用刀削一把刀时。当德怀特正在用刀削一把刀时，菲利斯想知道他是否还好。他想谈谈吗？她直视镜头。她说，你知道，我知道。你知道他们知道。菲利斯，俏皮的菲利斯，打破了第四面墙，把摄像组带了进来。是的。这是那个美味的德怀特-菲利斯片段的开始。是的。它将表现得如此美妙。
At the same time, Michael and Holly are planning their date. Well, Michael just blurts out. They're talking about where they're going to eat. Maybe they go to the food court. And he's like, well, I mean, it depends if we're going to have sex later. And then he was like, ah. And then, I mean, this is like how you know Holly is his soulmate. I mean, I know we see it over and over again, but she's like, hell yeah.
与此同时，迈克尔和霍莉正在计划他们的约会。嗯，迈克尔脱口而出。他们正在谈论去哪里吃饭。也许他们去美食广场。他说，嗯，我是说，这取决于我们稍后是否会发生性关系。然后他说，啊。然后，我是说，这就是你知道霍莉是他的灵魂伴侣的方式。我是说，我知道我们一次又一次地看到它，但她说，该死，是的。
I know. You're so worried that Michael has messed it up. Yeah. But he didn't because it's his soulmate. It's his soulmate. So at three minutes, 17 seconds for our background catch folks, did you see the Taco Bandito menu? No, I didn't see it. Yeah.
我知道。你很担心迈克尔搞砸了。是的。但他没有，因为那是他的灵魂伴侣。那是他的灵魂伴侣。所以在 3 分 17 秒，对于我们的背景捕捉粉丝，你看到 Taco Bandito 菜单了吗？不，我没看到。是的。
It's over Holly's shoulder. I looked it up. That is an actual restaurant in Scranton. It's on 211 North Main Avenue in Scranton. And that was Phil Shea getting us all those menus. Yes. Thanks to his inn from Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. That's right.
它在霍莉的肩膀上。我查过了。那是一家位于斯克兰顿的真实餐厅。它位于斯克兰顿北主大道 211 号。那是菲尔·谢伊为我们弄到的所有菜单。是的。多亏了他从我们的服装设计师嘉莉·贝内特那里得到的内幕。没错。
Taco Bandito. Working together to make it specific. Well, Michael is super excited about the fact that Holly is on board, third date sex. He has a talking head where he says he'll probably get soup, you know? Something light. Yeah. Well, Jenna, there were some deleted scenes that really showed how once Holly says, hell, yeah, Michael cannot think about anything else the rest of the day. I believe it.
Taco Bandito。共同努力使它具体化。嗯，迈克尔对霍莉同意第三次约会发生性关系的事实感到超级兴奋。他有一个谈话头，他说他可能会喝汤，你知道？清淡一点的东西。是的。嗯，珍娜，有一些删减场景真正展示了当霍莉说“该死，是的”后，迈克尔这一天剩下的时间里什么都想不了。我相信。
He is so distracted because he knows that he's going to have sex with Holly. There is a scene between Michael, Daryl, and Angela. Like, I never had scenes with Daryl and Michael. And Daryl and Angela are going over the warehouse budget. And Michael is just zoned out thinking about Holly. Sam, can you play it? The pallet trucks got a busted caster. We're still waiting on no safety goggles, and we need a new forklift.
他太分心了，因为他知道他要和霍莉发生性关系。迈克尔、达里尔和安吉拉之间有一个场景。就像，我从来没有和达里尔和迈克尔一起演过戏。达里尔和安吉拉正在检查仓库预算。迈克尔只是走神了，想着霍莉。萨姆，你能播放它吗？托盘车有一个坏掉的脚轮。我们还在等没有安全护目镜，我们需要一辆新的叉车。
Well, I can take maintenance cash and put it in a supply budget if Michael's okay with it. Michael, do you approve that? Hell yeah. Fine. Also, we have gnomes living in the wall. You mean rats? No. I mean a little scary man with red hats.
嗯，我可以拿维护现金，如果迈克尔同意的话，把它放进供应预算里。迈克尔，你批准吗？该死，是的。好的。另外，我们墙里住着侏儒。你是说老鼠？不。我是说一个戴着红帽子的小可怕男人。
I think they're drinking all our soda pop. You okay with that, Mike? Soda pop. Soda pop. I don't get it. Jenna, in the whole meeting, all he can say is hell yeah and soda pop. And he just looks so goofy through the whole meeting. Like, Holly has just said, hell yeah, and that's all Michael can process.
我想他们在喝我们所有的苏打水。你同意吗，迈克？苏打水。苏打水。我不明白。珍娜，在整个会议中，他只能说“该死，是的”和“苏打水”。他在整个会议中看起来太傻了。就像，霍莉刚刚说了“该死，是的”，而迈克尔只能处理这些。
Hell yeah. Angela, I really liked this scene in the break room between Dwight and Phyllis. When Dwight is telling Phyllis all of the things that Angela taught him in life, his time with her. Angela introduced him to pasteurized milk, to sheets, to presents on your birthday and preventative medicine. And monotheism. And monotheism. Look at all the things you've done. And then Dwight, he finally breaks down.
该死，是的。安吉拉，我真的很喜欢休息室里德怀特和菲利斯之间的这个场景。当德怀特告诉菲利斯安吉拉在他生活中教给他的所有事情，他与她在一起的时间。安吉拉向他介绍了巴氏杀菌奶、床单、生日礼物和预防医学。还有一神论。还有一神论。看看你所做的一切。然后德怀特，他终于崩溃了。
He gets a little vulnerable. He's like, why is she marrying him? And Phyllis says Angela's not much of a risk taker and Andy's not really a risk. She summed it up perfectly. She did. Angela took a risk on Dwight and she loved him and he put her cat in the freezer. She's not going to do that again. She's not.
他变得有点脆弱。他说，她为什么要嫁给他？菲利斯说安吉拉不是一个冒险者，安迪也不是真正的风险。她总结得非常完美。她做到了。安吉拉在德怀特身上冒了险，她爱他，而他把她的猫放进了冰箱。她不会再那样做了。她不会。
Well, Jenna, there was a deleted scene between Dwight and Phyllis that would just further this sort of conversation. But I'm sure it got cut for time. I saw it in the script and it was so funny. It's so funny. And they did actually shoot it. and it is in the deleted scenes. So this conversation continues. Dwight and Phyllis are now in the parking lot.
嗯，珍娜，德怀特和菲利斯之间有一个删减场景，会进一步推进这种对话。但我肯定它是为了时间而被剪掉的。我在剧本里看到了它，它太搞笑了。它太搞笑了。他们确实拍摄了它，它在删减场景中。所以这段对话继续。德怀特和菲利斯现在在停车场。
They're on the bench by the warehouse, and Dwight is eating a huge sandwich, and they're talking. And Dwight shares with Phyllis what he and Angela did on their very first date. This is so funny to me. Here's what their first date was. They went to the Anthracite Coal Museum tour. Yes. Yeah.
他们在仓库旁边的长椅上，德怀特正在吃一个巨大的三明治，他们在谈话。德怀特与菲利斯分享了他和安吉拉在第一次约会时做的事情。这对我来说太搞笑了。这是他们的第一次约会。他们去了无烟煤煤炭博物馆之旅。是的。是的。
Even though they had both been several times, They pretended like they'd never been so they could get all the extra information and special perks of the tour from the tour guide, even though the tour guides recognized both of them because they'd been there so many times. And then he said, yeah, and we corrected them when they got their information wrong. Talk about soulmates. Soulmates, these two want to go to the Anthracite Coal Museum tour, which they've done before, so that they can tell the tour guide when they get things wrong. Well, I looked it up, and Jenna, there is a Pennsylvania Anthrocyte, Site Heritage Museum. The museum is part of an anthracite museum complex created in 1971 by the Pennsylvania Historical and Museum Commission. But lady, there's three. There are three museums and one historical site located in their communities. Jenna, maybe put this on our list of places to go. Okay. The Pennsylvania Anthracite Heritage Museum and Scranton iron furnaces, both in Scranton, Eckley Minor,
即使他们都去过好几次，他们假装他们从来没去过，这样他们就可以从导游那里得到所有的额外信息和旅行的特殊福利，即使导游认出了他们两个，因为他们去过太多次了。然后他说，是的，当他们信息错误时，我们纠正了他们。谈谈灵魂伴侣。灵魂伴侣，这两个人想去无烟煤煤炭博物馆之旅，他们以前做过，这样他们就可以在导游出错时告诉他们。嗯，我查过了，珍娜，有一个宾夕法尼亚无烟煤遗产博物馆。该博物馆是 1971 年由宾夕法尼亚历史和博物馆委员会创建的无烟煤博物馆综合体的一部分。但女士，有三个。有三个博物馆和一个位于他们社区的历史遗址。珍娜，也许把这个列入我们的去处名单。好的。宾夕法尼亚无烟煤遗产博物馆和斯克兰顿铁炉，都在斯克兰顿，埃克利矿工，
village near Weatherly and the Museum of Anthracite Mining overlooking the community of Ashland. Plus, there are a few museum exhibits also located at the companion Lackawanna Coal Mine Tour. Okay, so the Lackawanna Coal Mine Tour is where Michael wanted to take the office as a reward in health care. In the mine shaft. So this is connected. Yes. So hopefully I said all those names correctly, but try saying Lackawanna Coal Mine Tour 10 times fast. I'm going to do it.
韦瑟利附近的村庄和俯瞰阿什兰社区的无烟煤采矿博物馆。另外，还有一些博物馆展览也位于配套的拉卡瓦纳煤矿之旅中。好的，所以拉卡瓦纳煤矿之旅是迈克尔在医疗保健中想带办公室去作为奖励的地方。在矿井里。所以这是连接起来的。是的。所以希望我正确地说了所有这些名字，但试着快速说十遍“拉卡瓦纳煤矿之旅”。我要做。
tonight. This is apparently one of Dwight and Angel's favorite places to go, and they went on their first date. That is some very sweet backstory into this couple. Now we have a scene where Michael and Holly are trying to kill time before their dinner reservation. So they're playing crazy AIDS. So cute. But as they get ready to leave and they're walking out, Holly says she forgot her keys. They need to go back in. But then she says she didn't forget her keys. Not Only that. When they go back in, she turns around and locks the door and gives a look to camera. Mm-hmm. She's ready to get it on. She wants to make out in the stairway. Yeah. She's worried we can hear them, though. Yeah, but Michael says, don't worry. Just turn the style all the way this way and you'll turn everything off. And now they're just so loud. He's done it the wrong way. It's really pretty amazing. The following morning, people are arriving to work. Michael and Holly are glowing. But there's police. Outside the building, there has been a burglary.
今晚。这显然是德怀特和安吉拉最喜欢去的地方之一，他们第一次约会就去了那里。这对夫妇有一些非常甜蜜的背景故事。现在我们有一个场景，迈克尔和霍莉在晚餐预订前试图消磨时间。所以他们在玩疯狂艾滋病。太可爱了。但当他们准备离开并走出去时，霍莉说她忘了钥匙。他们需要回去。但随后她说她没忘钥匙。不仅如此。当他们回去时，她转过身锁上门，并向镜头看了一眼。嗯哼。她准备好开始了。她想在楼梯间亲热。是的。不过她担心我们能听到他们。是的，但迈克尔说，别担心。只要把样式一直转到这边，你就会关掉一切。现在他们太吵了。他转错了方向。这真的很神奇。第二天早上，人们到达工作地点。迈克尔和霍莉容光焕发。但有警察。在大楼外面，发生了一起入室盗窃。
Yeah. Stuff has been stolen. Yeah. We had a fan question. Okay. From Lackland A. When Michael and Holly come into the office in the morning, we saw a police car, but we never see any police officers. Was this a continuity error?
是的。东西被偷了。是的。我们有一个粉丝问题。好的。来自拉克兰 A。当迈克尔和霍莉早上来到办公室时，我们看到了一辆警车，但我们从来没有看到任何警察。这是一个连续性错误吗？
No. There were police officers, but they're in the deleted scenes. That's right. And there's a really funny scene between Dwight and a police officer in the script. It was really simple. Dwight is asking the police officer, do you need any crime scene tape? And the police officer is like, you have crime scene tape? And Dwight looks at him like, duh, do you need it? Yeah, exactly. So we did have police officers, but they got cut out. They are in the deleted scenes. That little scene is there. And it's very funny.
不。有警察，但他们在删减场景中。没错。剧本里德怀特和一名警察之间有一个非常有趣的场景。它非常简单。德怀特问警察，你需要犯罪现场胶带吗？警察说，你有犯罪现场胶带？德怀特看着他，就像，废话，你需要吗？是的，完全正确。所以我们确实有警察，但他们被剪掉了。他们在删减场景中。那个小场景在那里。而且非常有趣。
Well, there has been quite a robbery. A lot was taken. Well, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, let's figure out, What was taken? Who did it? What's happening? What is happening? We are back. There's been a burglary at the office. Angela, what was stolen? Tell us what are we missing? How did you say burglary? Burglary? Burglary? Burglary? It's a weird word, right? What did I say? I don't know. I don't know. It sounded like you were like burglary. I don't know. You know what? It is a weird word. Burglary. Burglary. Burglary. It sounds like gibberish.
嗯，确实发生了一起抢劫案。很多东西被拿走了。嗯，我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们弄清楚，什么被拿走了？谁做的？发生了什么？发生了什么？我们回来了。办公室发生了入室盗窃。安吉拉，什么被偷了？告诉我们我们缺少什么？你怎么说入室盗窃？入室盗窃？入室盗窃？入室盗窃？这是一个奇怪的词，对吧？我说了什么？我不知道。我不知道。听起来你就像入室盗窃。我不知道。你知道吗？它确实是一个奇怪的词。入室盗窃。入室盗窃。入室盗窃。听起来像胡言乱语。
Like, oh my God, what happened to your house? I had a bugler. Yeah. It's like a thing you say frantically. And if you read it exactly as it spelled, it's burglary. I had a burglary. Well, what was stolen in the burglary? Okay.
就像，哦，天哪，你的房子发生了什么？我有一个窃贼。是的。这就像你疯狂说的一件事。如果你完全按照拼写读它，它是入室盗窃。我有一个入室盗窃。嗯，入室盗窃中偷了什么？好的。
According to Dwight, there were security tapes taken, obviously, to cover the thief's tracks. He also thinks that maybe the robber. were vintage HP computer collectors, so I'm guessing a few of the computers are gone. A lot of blank checks, Angela is calling in to the bank to cancel them, Oscar's laptop, Kevin's surge protector, and in deleted scenes, we find out Stanley had a delicious bottle of cream sherry that he was saving to drink on his last day at Dundermifflin. So now he's going to have to replace that. Now, Angela, correct me if I'm wrong. But Oscar has this line where he says, I have to get my laptop back.
根据德怀特的说法，安全带被拿走了，显然是为了掩盖小偷的踪迹。他还认为也许抢劫者是老式惠普电脑收藏家，所以我猜几台电脑不见了。很多空白支票，安吉拉正在打电话给银行取消它们，奥斯卡的笔记本电脑，凯文的电涌保护器，在删减场景中，我们发现斯坦利有一瓶美味的奶油雪利酒，他一直留着想在邓德·米夫林工作的最后一天喝。所以现在他不得不更换它。现在，安吉拉，如果我错了请纠正我。但奥斯卡有这句台词，他说，我必须拿回我的笔记本电脑。
Oh, no, lady, I have way hold up. Oh, my God, I'm flipping pages. The line she's talking about is going to happen at eight minutes, seven seconds. Now, didn't you guys think he sounded like Jimmy Stewart? Okay, there's a blooper. Oscar says, I don't want to talk. I want my laptop back. and for whatever reason, when we were filming this, it was after lunch, and Oscar had to walk out to, like, the main bullpen, and he had to say, I don't want to talk, I want my laptop back. He couldn't get the line out. And when he finally got the line out, he went like this. I don't want to talk. I want my laptop back. Yeah. And I said, in the moment, in character, I said, what are you, Jimmy Stewart? And the place lost it.
哦，不，女士，我等一下。哦，天哪，我在翻页。她谈论的那句台词将在 8 分 7 秒发生。现在，你们不觉得他听起来像吉米·斯图尔特吗？好的，有一个花絮。奥斯卡说，我不想谈。我想要回我的笔记本电脑。无论出于什么原因，当我们拍摄这个时，是在午餐后，奥斯卡不得不走到像主办公室的地方，他不得不说，我不想谈，我想要回我的笔记本电脑。他无法说出这句台词。当他最终说出这句台词时，他这样做了。我不想谈。我想要回我的笔记本电脑。是的。我说，在那一刻，在角色中，我说，你是吉米·斯图尔特吗？那个地方失去了它。
We all lost it because he was like, I want my laptop back. But then if I remember correctly, once he'd done it, he couldn't get rid of it. He couldn't get rid of it. And then everybody jumped on it. So then Rain and John and everyone started going, I want my laptop back. Okay. So I was not there when you filmed this scene. But when I came back, you guys saying, I want my laptop back.
我们都失去了它，因为他就像，我想要回我的笔记本电脑。但如果我没记错的话，一旦他做了，他就无法摆脱它。他无法摆脱它。然后每个人都跳了上去。所以雷恩和约翰以及每个人都开始说，我想要回我的笔记本电脑。好的。所以我拍摄这个场景时不在那里。但当我回来时，你们说，我想要回我的笔记本电脑。
That went on for years. Years. That was a bit. And I was like, what is it? What happened? And Oscar was like, F, you guys. But he was just like, he got tongue tied after lunch. Listen, that happened on our show.
这种情况持续了好几年。好几年。那只是个小插曲。我当时想，那是什么？发生了什么？奥斯卡说，去你的，你们这些家伙。但他只是午饭后说话有点结巴。听着，那是在我们的节目里发生的。
Big bullpen scenes after lunch, we would get loopy. You know what lived on forever too? Is when I said, you send us all these filthy emails. John Krasinski said that to me for years. Were they filthy? I want my laptop back. You're filthy emails. your filthy emails.
午饭后牛棚里的大场面，我们会变得很疯。你知道还有什么一直存在吗？就是我说，你们发给我们所有这些肮脏的邮件。约翰·卡拉辛斯基好几年都这么对我说。它们很肮脏吗？我想拿回我的笔记本电脑。你们这些肮脏的邮件。你们这些肮脏的邮件。
I want you to know that Kevin is really, really concerned about his surge protector. He's worried about searches. This sent me down a road. I needed to know more about power surges. And I am not going to bore you with everything I read. I will give you this one nugget because I didn't know it. I'm telling you, I want a screen grab of your search engine. I know.
我想让你知道，凯文真的非常非常担心他的电涌保护器。他担心电涌。这让我走上了一条路。我需要更多地了解电涌。我不会用我读到的所有东西来让你感到无聊。我会给你这个小知识点，因为我以前不知道。我告诉你，我想要一张你的搜索引擎的截图。我知道。
I'm going to frame it. I know. I thought power surges were just like giant things that happened. like some lightning strikes or something, and I need a surge protector because of like, you know, big moments. Can't they happen just because you have too much stuff plugged in? Like I blow dried my hair one time and it blew out the outlet. Yeah. There's something called mini surges.
我要把它装裱起来。我知道。我以为电涌就像发生的巨大事情一样。比如闪电击中什么的，我需要一个电涌保护器是因为，你知道，重大时刻。它们不能仅仅因为你插了太多东西而发生吗？比如我曾经吹过头发，然后把插座吹坏了。是的。有一种东西叫微型电涌。
And that happens every time your air conditioner kicks on. Like you get a mini surge and it can slowly damage your appliances over time. Oh. Because your house can get like a buildup of mini surges. So Kevin is right. You really need to surge protect your house. I also found out you can get a whole house surge suppressor. They connect to your fuse box. I don't even know if I have one. I need to find out because I got so worried about surges after my search. I feel like you would know if you had a surge suppressor. I mean, we probably do. That's Lee's department. He handles that stuff. Right. You know, we divide things up more traditionally in that way. If it's electrical or yard oriented, that's on Lee. So I should ask him. I'm the yard person at my house. I love the yard.
每次你的空调启动时都会发生这种情况。就像你会得到一个微型电涌，随着时间的推移，它会慢慢损坏你的电器。哦。因为你的房子可能会积聚微型电涌。所以凯文是对的。你真的需要给你的房子安装电涌保护。我还发现你可以买一个全屋电涌抑制器。它们连接到你的保险丝盒上。我甚至不知道我有没有。我需要查清楚，因为我在搜索之后对电涌感到非常担心。我觉得如果你有电涌抑制器你会知道的。我的意思是，我们可能有的。那是李的部门。他负责那些事情。对。你知道，我们以更传统的方式划分事情。如果是电气的或与院子有关的，那是李负责的。所以我应该问他。我是我家院子的人。我喜欢院子。
I love being outside. I love to garden. I know our sprinkler system. I set it. I'm like station fours looking wonky. Let's fix that. Yeah, that's on Lee. I've got my allergies.
我喜欢待在外面。我喜欢园艺。我知道我们的喷水系统。我设置了它。我心想四号站看起来不太对劲。让我们修好它。是的，那是李负责的。我有我的过敏症。
I'm inside. You're inside person. Well, listen, Michael and Holly are starting to connect the dots. They're like, oh, no. Oh, no. Wait, did we lock? Did you lock it? I didn't lock it.
我在里面。你是室内的人。好吧，听着，迈克尔和霍莉开始把点连起来了。他们心想，哦，不。哦，不。等等，我们锁了吗？你锁了吗？我没锁。
Oh, no. This is their fault. So much for sex without consequences. Yes, that is Michael's talking head. But Jenna, there was an alt in the script that made me laugh so hard. There was one extra line. And this was the other version of this talking head. So much for sex without consequences.
哦，不。这是他们的错。没有后果的性爱到此为止。是的，那是迈克尔的访谈。但是珍娜，剧本里有一个备选方案让我笑得好厉害。多了一行台词。这是这个访谈的另一个版本。没有后果的性爱到此为止。
Well, I guess with great sex comes great responsibility. Yes. And that one was deleted. That is such a good line. I know. During all of this mayhem, Jim is literally. listening to a message from Pam. It's a but dial message.
好吧，我想伟大的性爱伴随着伟大的责任。是的。而那一句被删除了。那真是一句好台词。我知道。在所有这些混乱中，吉姆正在听帕姆的留言。这是一个误拨的留言。
It goes on and on. Clearly, she went out last night. Sounds like she had another volcano. Yeah. She's out partying with her art school pals. They're whipping it up. Wipping it? Wipping it up.
它没完没了。显然，她昨晚出去了。听起来她又爆发了。是的。她和她的艺术学校伙伴们出去聚会了。他们正在狂欢。狂欢？正在狂欢。
I think they're whipping it up. Yeah. And Jim is just kind of like future mother of my children right there. Yep. Which is what Lee said when I got home from my bachelorette party that you hosted, Angela. and I was throwing up in the bushes. He said, you're the future mother of my children. I couldn't be prouder of you.
我想他们正在狂欢。是的。而吉姆只是那种，未来的孩子们的母亲就在那里。是的。这就是当我从你主持的单身派对回来时，李对我说的，安吉拉。当时我在灌木丛里呕吐。他说，你是我的孩子们的未来母亲。我为你感到无比自豪。
Angela says she's never felt safe here. Andy says she's safe with him because he's a very good screamer. That made me laugh so hard. Dwight has grabbed Phyllis. They're in the elevator. He had to talk to her right away. He says he knows that Angela loves him. She's practically told him so.
安吉拉说她在这里从来没有感到安全过。安迪说她和他在一起很安全，因为他是一个非常好的尖叫者。那让我笑得好厉害。德怀特抓住了菲利斯。他们在电梯里。他必须马上和她谈谈。他说他知道安吉拉爱他。她几乎已经告诉他了。
Well, Phyllis says then you need to offer her an ultimatum. That's what Bob did to Phyllis. Yeah. He said she had to stop talking to her sister so much. Oh, Phyllis. I know. Well, Jen Salada shared that shooting this elevator scene was crazy because we do not actually have a working elevator. Remember, we've shared before that if we went into the elevator, we would shoot part of the scene and then we would have to relocate to the other building where
好吧，菲利斯说那你需要给她一个最后通牒。那是鲍勃对菲利斯做的。是的。他说她必须停止和她姐姐说那么多话。哦，菲利斯。我知道。好吧，珍·萨拉达分享说拍摄这个电梯场景很疯狂，因为我们实际上没有一个能用的电梯。记得我们之前分享过，如果我们进入电梯，我们会拍摄场景的一部分，然后我们必须搬到另一栋楼，那里
the bottom of the elevator is. Right. And the lobby. And there were always guys sort of standing on either side off camera with ropes and they would pull the doors open and they would shut the doors. That is a pulley system door, you guys. There was nothing electric about that elevator. It is super faky, fake, old-timey, just pullies and people. And ropes. Making this box of wood turn into an elevator. Well, she said that they didn't want to relocate. So they did this crazy thing, which is so amazing. What they did was while Phyllis and Dwight are inside the elevator doing the scene, a bunch of crew members came out and redressed the front part hallway of the elevator.
是电梯的底部。对。还有大厅。而且总是有家伙站在摄像机外的两边，拿着绳子，他们会拉开门，然后关上门。那是一个滑轮系统门，伙计们。那个电梯一点也不电气化。它超级假，假的，老式的，只是滑轮和人。还有绳子。让这个木盒子变成一个电梯。好吧，她说他们不想搬迁。所以他们做了这件疯狂的事情，这太神奇了。他们做的是，当菲利斯和德怀特在电梯里拍摄场景时，一群工作人员出来重新布置了电梯的前厅。
So they came in, they put carpeting over the tile and they added a potted plant so that when the doors opened again and Phyllis stepped out, it would look like a new floor. They were in their correct place. And Jen said, if you look closely, when Phyllis gets out of the elevator, the plant is still moving because they had to just like slap that plant down really quickly and book it out of there. That to me feels like theater. That's what it's like when you do a play. It's like, you have three seconds to reset dress the area while you're putting a blouse on over the other blouse.
所以他们进来，在瓷砖上铺上地毯，并增加了一盆盆栽，这样当门再次打开，菲利斯走出来时，它看起来就像一个新的楼层。他们在正确的地方。珍说，如果你仔细看，当菲利斯走出电梯时，植物还在移动，因为他们必须非常快地把那盆植物放下来，然后跑开。这对我来说感觉就像戏剧。这就是你演戏时的样子。就像，你有三秒钟的时间重新布置区域，同时你还要在另一件衬衫上穿上一件衬衫。
And then a bunch of guys are sliding a sofa onto the stage. and then you walk out and the lights come up. Yes, totally. And, you know, they had to do multiple takes of this. So that day at work, there were these people who just, like, threw down carpeting and picked up carpeting and threw down a plant and picked up a plant over and over again. And grab the ropes and pulled the elevator and jumped the elevator. Yes. Aw.
然后一群家伙把沙发滑到舞台上。然后你走出来，灯光亮起。是的，完全正确。而且，你知道，他们必须多次拍摄这个场景。所以那天在工作中，有这些人，就像，扔下地毯，捡起地毯，扔下一盆植物，捡起一盆植物，一遍又一遍。然后抓住绳子，拉动电梯，跳过电梯。是的。啊。
Movie magic. Sometimes it's just practical. Yep. Meanwhile, there is a lot of hubbub about the burglary. Holly says her door is open if anyone wants to talk. Creed has his amazing talking head. It's so good. He says nobody steals from him and gets away with it.
电影魔法。有时它只是实用的。是的。与此同时，关于入室盗窃有很多喧嚣。霍莉说如果有人想谈谈，她的门是开着的。克里德有他惊人的访谈。太棒了。他说没有人能从他那里偷东西还能逃脱惩罚。
You know the last person who did that? They disappeared and his name was Creed Bratton. My favorite part though is he goes, his name, Creed Bratton. Yeah. He like whispers his own name. Clearly he has killed Creed Bratton and taken his identity. What's happening? That's what you're led to believe.
你知道最后一个这样做的人吗？他们消失了，他的名字叫克里德·布拉顿。不过我最喜欢的部分是他说了，他的名字，克里德·布拉顿。是的。他像是在耳语他自己的名字。显然他杀了克里德·布拉顿并窃取了他的身份。发生了什么？这就是你被引导去相信的。
Well, Michael's going to make everything right. He's going to call a conference room meeting and he has an idea. He's going to have a charity auction. Right. It's going to be called crime aid. And it's like farm aid, but instead of farms fighting AIDS, it's going to be us fighting our own poverty. No one likes the idea.
好吧，迈克尔要让一切变得正确。他要召开一个会议室会议，他有一个主意。他要举办一个慈善拍卖会。对。它将被命名为犯罪援助。就像农场援助，但不是农场对抗艾滋病，而是我们对抗我们自己的贫困。没有人喜欢这个主意。
But Phyllis. Phyllis is like, yeah, we did this in my sorority. We can, you know, auction off fun things like tennis lessons. We had a few people right in. They were wondering, why do we have? to have a charity auction. Like, wouldn't the insurance cover the cost of the missing items? I think this is a good question. Charlie Grandi, our writer, said that there was a scene that got cut for time in which Michael would have explained that their insurance has a $5,000
但是菲利斯。菲利斯说，是的，我们在我的联谊会里做过这个。我们可以，你知道，拍卖一些有趣的东西，比如网球课。我们有几个人写信进来。他们想知道，为什么我们必须举办慈善拍卖会？保险难道不能覆盖丢失物品的费用吗？我认为这是一个好问题。我们的编剧查理·格兰迪说，有一个场景因为时间原因被剪掉了，迈克尔本可以在那个场景中解释他们的保险有5000美元的
deductible for personal items. They lost less than $5,000 worth of stuff, so none of that was covered. That's true. It's a scene between Michael and Holly, and Holly explains to Michael that personal items are not covered. And so that is the reason for this big auction. As they're sort of discussing this in the conference room, Angela's like, who would come to this? Michael's like, I don't know, pedestrians, looky-loose. That was my favorite. I know.
个人物品免赔额。他们丢失的东西价值不到5000美元，所以这些都没有被覆盖。这是真的。这是迈克尔和霍莉之间的一个场景，霍莉向迈克尔解释个人物品不在覆盖范围内。所以这就是举办这场大型拍卖会的原因。当他们在会议室讨论这个问题时，安吉拉说，谁会来参加这个？迈克尔说，我不知道，行人，看热闹的人。那是我最喜欢的。我知道。
Look-y-loose. Look-y-lose. Maybe Bruce Springsteen fans. Everyone's like, what? Yeah, Michael says he has scored Springsteen tickets and he's going to auction them off. Jenna, I have a Springsteen story. What is it? You guys know I interned on Conan O'Brien, right? Yeah. In my early 20s. So I was Max Weinberg's intern. Max was the band leader for the Conan O'Brien show. But boss fans know that he was also the drummer for Bruce Springsteen and the E Street band. So here I am, Jenna.
看热闹的人。看热闹的人。也许是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的粉丝。每个人都说，什么？是的，迈克尔说他搞到了斯普林斯汀的票，他要拍卖它们。珍娜，我有一个关于斯普林斯汀的故事。是什么？你们知道我在柯南·奥布莱恩那里实习过，对吧？是的。在我20多岁的时候。所以我曾是马克斯·温伯格的实习生。马克斯是柯南·奥布莱恩节目的乐队指挥。但老板的粉丝们知道他也是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀和E街乐队的鼓手。所以我在这里，珍娜。
I'm this young intern. Max comes out of his office and says, hey, Bruce Springsteen's going to be calling me. I'm going to be down in the studio. I'm going to need you to forward his call to me. And I was like, what? What? And I was like cold sweat. He was like, yeah, he should call, you know, while I'm down there. I was like, okay. I sat by that phone. I had to pee. I was like, I can't go pee. I can't go pee. Bruce Springsteen is calling. I know. And then I was like, wait, I don't know how to forward. No one showed me that. I sat there sweating it. And then Max comes back up. And I was like, Bruce never called. I sat here the whole time. Jenna, I almost peed my pants. never called? He was like, oh, well, he might call later today. Sometime today. I was like,
我是这个年轻的实习生。马克斯从他的办公室出来说，嘿，布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀要给我打电话。我要去演播室。我需要你把他的电话转给我。我当时想，什么？什么？我当时冷汗直流。他说，是的，他应该会打来，你知道，当我在下面的时候。我说，好的。我坐在电话旁。我想尿尿。我心想，我不能去尿尿。我不能去尿尿。布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀要打电话。我知道。然后我心想，等等，我不知道怎么转接。没有人教过我。我坐在那里出汗。然后马克斯回来了。我说，布鲁斯从来没打过电话。我一直坐在这里。珍娜，我差点尿裤子了。从来没打过？他说，哦，好吧，他可能今天晚些时候会打。今天某个时候。我说，
sometime today. I thought I like couldn't leave my phone right then and there. And then one time someone dropped off a package from Bruce for Max and there was a little card on the outside and it just said dash B. Like 2Max dash B. I was like, oh my God, I am holding a card that Bruce Springsteen wrote on that B is him. That's pretty cool. Wait, but you never got to hear. his voice on the phone. Jenna, this is not the best story. I just want you to know I waited for a call from him. I almost got to talk to him. It didn't happen, but I did get to hold a piece of paper he wrote on. Well, I got to see Bruce Springsteen live on Broadway when he did his Broadway show and it was fantastic. Did you talk to him? No. And I've also never held a card that says dash B. So I think you're closer. I'm closer to meeting the boss. You are. Dwight is going to take Phyllis's advice. He is going to give Angela an ultimatum. She has until 6.14 p.m. to break up with Andy, apologize, and start dating Dwight.
今天某个时候。我以为我当时不能离开我的电话。然后有一次有人送来一个布鲁斯给马克斯的包裹，外面有一张小卡片，上面只写着破折号B。就像2Max破折号B。我心想，天哪，我拿着一张布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀写的卡片，那个B就是他。那很酷。等等，但你从来没有听到过。他在电话里的声音。珍娜，这不是最好的故事。我只是想让你知道我等了他的电话。我差点就能和他说话了。没发生，但我确实拿到了他写的一张纸。好吧，我有幸在百老汇现场看了布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的演出，当时他做了他的百老汇秀，非常棒。你和他说话了吗？没有。而且我也从来没有拿过写着破折号B的卡片。所以我认为你更接近。我更接近见到老板。你是。德怀特要听从菲利斯的建议。他要给安吉拉一个最后通牒。她有直到下午6点14分的时间和安迪分手，道歉，并开始和德怀特约会。
Or you don't get any of this. We could not get through it. It's in the bloopers. We both started laughing. It was so ridiculous. This is a fantastic ultimatum, though. I know. Angela, is it time for the auction?
否则你就得不到这些了。我们无法完成它。它在花絮里。我们俩都开始笑了。太荒谬了。不过这是一个很棒的最后通牒。我知道。安吉拉，是时候拍卖了吗？
It is time for crime reduces, in a sense, makes everyone angry. I declare. Yes. Michael says there may not be a Wikipedia entry for office robbery statistics, yet its victims are standing strong together. So there is still no Wikipedia page for office robbery statistics, and I'll tell you why. Because you looked it up. After the show aired, fans kept trying to make a Wikipedia page for office robbery statistics. and Wikipedia had to keep taking it down. So now if you type in Office Robbery Statistics, Wikipedia will direct you to the episode Crime Aid, and there is a note that says, Office Robbery Statistics was redirected to this page to prevent further attempted creations.
是时候犯罪减少了，从某种意义上说，让每个人都生气。我宣布。是的。迈克尔说，办公室抢劫统计数据可能还没有维基百科条目，但它的受害者正站在一起。所以办公室抢劫统计数据仍然没有维基百科页面，我会告诉你为什么。因为你查过了。节目播出后，粉丝们一直试图为办公室抢劫统计数据制作一个维基百科页面。而维基百科不得不一直把它删掉。所以现在如果你输入办公室抢劫统计数据，维基百科会把你引导到犯罪援助这一集，并且有一个注释说，办公室抢劫统计数据被重定向到此页面以防止进一步的创建尝试。
Oh my gosh. You guys are persistent. Also, we had a fan question from Brandon L. who wanted to know who wrote the acronym Crime Aid for the show. Guys, this was all Charlie Grandy. He said he spent three hours writing various combinations, and he settled on this one. Oh, I love that it took him three hours.
天哪。你们真执着。另外，我们有一个来自布兰登·L的粉丝问题，他想知道是谁为节目写了犯罪援助这个缩写。伙计们，这全是查理·格兰迪写的。他说他花了三个小时写了各种组合，最后定下了这个。哦，我喜欢它花了他三个小时。
That just feeds my soul, because how many times, Jenna, have you and I sat down to write something? And I'm like, well, I spent half an hour on two words. Yes. Combinations. It's time for the auction to start. We've got good stuff. We do. I have a list of what all was auctioned off.
这真的滋养了我的灵魂，因为珍娜，你和我坐下来写东西有多少次了？而我心想，好吧，我在两个词上花了半个小时。是的。组合。是时候开始拍卖了。我们有好东西。我们有。我有一份所有拍卖物品的清单。
Ready? Yes. We have a yoga lesson from Holly, sold to Michael for $300 because no one else would bid on it. Bears with the warehouse guys from Daryl sold to Jim for $5. But you have to go right now. It's beers right now with the warehouse guys. Yes, and there was a scripted Jim talking head that didn't make it in that would explain why he felt like he could leave right away. Jim says, Pam loves Bruce Springsteen. I love Bruce Springsteen, and I'm really excited about these tickets.
准备好了吗？是的。我们有霍莉的瑜伽课，以300美元卖给了迈克尔，因为没有其他人出价。达里尔的仓库伙计们的啤酒以5美元卖给了吉姆。但你现在必须去。现在是和仓库伙计们喝啤酒。是的，还有一个剧本里的吉姆访谈没有放进去，它会解释为什么他觉得他可以马上离开。吉姆说，帕姆喜欢布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。我喜欢布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀，我对这些票感到非常兴奋。
My one reservation is that Bruce Springsteen is not currently touring, so I'm leaving. All right. The next thing auctioned off was a Creed all-inclusive. Creed. He's auctioning off himself. No bids. Kevin will do your taxes, federal and state. No bids. Hank sings the blues and he's auctioning off his CDs. No bids that we see anyway. Mm-hmm. David Wallace coming in strong, auctioning off a weekend at his home on Martha's Vineyard.
我唯一保留的是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀目前没有巡演，所以我走了。好的。接下来拍卖的是克里德全包。克里德。他在拍卖他自己。没有出价。凯文会帮你做税，联邦和州。没有出价。汉克唱蓝调，他正在拍卖他的CD。我们看到的没有出价。嗯。大卫·华莱士强势登场，拍卖他在玛莎葡萄园岛家中的一个周末。
Multiple bids. We don't know where it landed. Phyllis auctions off a hug. Bob wins that one for $1,000. And in deleted scenes, Kelly auctions off dance lessons. And also, Meredith mumbles something. No one can tell what she's saying.
多次出价。我们不知道它落在了哪里。菲利斯拍卖一个拥抱。鲍勃以1000美元赢得了那个。在删除的场景中，凯利拍卖舞蹈课。还有，梅雷迪思嘟囔着什么。没人能听出她在说什么。
Oscar says, fine, I bid a dollar. And then she tosses him a brand new iPhone. That's so funny. Everyone's like, what? That's all the items auctioned. According to the bar graph thingy, it looks like they raised $1,803. I have a lot of fan questions and catches based on everything you said, Angela, starting with Audrey E. During the auction, there's a giant goal thermometer.
奥斯卡说，好吧，我出价一美元。然后她扔给他一个全新的iPhone。太搞笑了。每个人都说，什么？这就是所有拍卖的物品。根据条形图，看起来他们筹集了1803美元。根据你所说的一切，安吉拉，我有很多粉丝问题和捕捉，从奥黛丽·E开始。在拍卖期间，有一个巨大的目标温度计。
but the goal isn't at the top of the thermometer. It's like they're only trying to fill it part way up. That's a really funny detail. Yes. This detail was an intentional joke that was written into the script. In the script, it says, the amount raised thermometer goes up to $1 million, even though the goal is $3,400, which should be written a little over a foot from the bottom. That was a script note.
但目标不在温度计的顶部。就像他们只试图填满它的一部分。这是一个非常有趣的细节。是的。这个细节是一个故意的笑话，写在剧本里。在剧本里，它说，筹款温度计上升到100万美元，尽管目标是3400美元，这应该写在底部上方一点点。那是一个剧本注释。
Yeah. So, yes, very funny little detail. And did you notice whenever Michael was being the auctioneer, if bids started going high, he would throw in a million dollars? He'd be like, $100, $200, $1 million. Okay, $400. We had a fan catch from many people, Erica P, Rob O, KD, and Ashley S. When Jim leaves to go to the bar with Daryl, Michael auctions off Creed. But if you look, Jim is seated behind Creed.
是的。所以，是的，非常有趣的小细节。你有没有注意到每当迈克尔担任拍卖师时，如果出价开始变高，他就会投入一百万美元？他会说，100美元，200美元，100万美元。好的，400美元。我们有一个来自许多人的粉丝捕捉，埃里卡·P，罗布·O，KD，和阿什利·S。当吉姆离开去和达里尔去酒吧时，迈克尔拍卖了克里德。但如果你看，吉姆坐在克里德后面。
Oh, good catch. Jim should not be there, but clearly we moved those scenes around. Yep. Also, fan question from Catherine D. Lexi B. and Maddie L. Is Hank really a blues musician? No. So not only is Hugh Dane, who plays Hank, not a blues musician, he had never played the guitar before that day.
哦，好捕捉。吉姆不应该在那里，但显然我们移动了那些场景。是的。还有，来自凯瑟琳·D，莱克西·B和马迪·L的粉丝问题。汉克真的是蓝调音乐家吗？不。所以不仅是扮演汉克的休·戴恩不是蓝调音乐家，他在那天之前从来没有弹过吉他。
And this bit about Hank being a blues musician was a holdover from an earlier draft of the script, Jen Salada told me, it didn't even make it in the shooting draft, but there was a whole storyline where Oscar and Kevin were going to try to solve the crime of who broke into the office. And they decide that it must be an inside job because the door wasn't broken. So they're interviewing everyone. They interview Hank and they say, Hank, do you have a record? And Hank says, I do have a record. But it's a blues record, not a criminal record.
而这个关于汉克是蓝调音乐家的片段是剧本早期草稿的遗留物，珍·萨拉达告诉我，它甚至没有进入拍摄草稿，但有一个完整的故事线，奥斯卡和凯文要试图解决谁闯入办公室的犯罪。他们认为这一定是一个内部工作，因为门没有被破坏。所以他们正在采访每个人。他们采访汉克，他们说，汉克，你有犯罪记录吗？汉克说，我确实有记录。但那是蓝调唱片，不是犯罪记录。
So Jen always loved that joke that Hank said, I have a record, I have a blues record. So she said I want Hank to auction off his blues record at this auction. But it was a super last minute pitch. Jen told me they only had a couple hours to make the prop CD, which is why if you notice, Hank is wearing the same outfit in the CD that he's wearing in the episode. Well, and it also said in the script that Hank plays very poorly. And we're all having to sit there and listen. Angela, because of this auction, I became inspired to find out what are some of the world's best-selling auction items?
所以珍一直很喜欢汉克说的那个笑话，我有记录，我有蓝调唱片。所以她说我想让汉克在这个拍卖会上拍卖他的蓝调唱片。但这是一个超级最后一分钟的提议。珍告诉我他们只有几个小时的时间来制作道具CD，这就是为什么如果你注意到，汉克在CD里穿的衣服和他在剧集里穿的一模一样。好吧，而且剧本里也说汉克弹得很差。而我们都不得不坐在那里听。安吉拉，因为这次拍卖，我受到启发去找出世界上一些最畅销的拍卖品是什么？
Like what you see in the news, like Christy's auctioned off a Picasso or something like that? Yes. Okay. Yes. I have a list. Of the highest paid items ever at an auction? Yes. Oh.
就像你在新闻里看到的，比如佳士得拍卖了一幅毕加索什么的？是的。好的。是的。我有一份清单。有史以来拍卖会上支付最高的物品？是的。哦。
In certain categories. Oh. For example, the world's most. expensive work of art sold at auction was a 500-year-old painting of Jesus Christ, believed to have been painted by Leonardo da Vinci. Ooh, I was going to say Da Vinci's on this list. I really was. Okay, go. The painting is known as Salvatore Mundi, which means savior of the world, and it sold at Christie's auction in 2017 for $450 million. Dang. Who bought it? I don't know.
在某些类别中。哦。例如，世界上最。昂贵的艺术品在拍卖会上售出的是一幅500年前的耶稣基督画作，据信是由列奥纳多·达·芬奇绘制的。哦，我本来要说达·芬奇在这个名单上。我真的要说了。好的，继续。这幅画被称为救世主，意思是世界的救世主，它在2017年的佳士得拍卖会上以4.5亿美元的价格售出。该死。谁买的？我不知道。
Oh, my God. I wouldn't want you. to know that I have that. I mean, that feels like a security risk. Right. It's got to be anonymous. I don't know if it is or not, but it didn't say. The record for the most expensive work of art by a living artist goes to Jeff Coons, his rabbit sculpture, which sold for $91.1 million in May of 2019. Wow. Jeff Coons actually has two of the top five items. that were most expensive for a living artist. Also, his dog sculpture is like balloon dog. Wow.
哦，天哪。我不想让你。知道我有那个。我的意思是，这感觉像是一个安全风险。对。它必须是匿名的。我不知道它是不是，但它没说。最昂贵的在世艺术家艺术品的记录属于杰夫·昆斯，他的兔子雕塑，在2019年5月以9110万美元的价格售出。哇。杰夫·昆斯实际上有前五名中的两件物品。是在世艺术家中最昂贵的。还有，他的狗雕塑就像气球狗。哇。
The most expensive dress ever sold at an auction? Oh, can I guess? Yes. Was it either Audrey Hepburn or like Princess Diana? It's Marilyn Monroe. Oh, Marilyn Monroe! Why did they say Marilyn Monroe? Her happy birthday, Mr. President gown. Oh, yes.
拍卖会上售出的最昂贵的裙子？哦，我可以猜吗？是的。是奥黛丽·赫本还是戴安娜王妃？是玛丽莲·梦露。哦，玛丽莲·梦露！他们为什么说玛丽莲·梦露？她的生日快乐，总统先生礼服。哦，是的。
It sold for $4.8 million in 2016. The most expensive wrist watch ever auctioned. I mean, I found this fascinating because I was like, really, a watch sold for $31 million. I don't get it. It's called a Petech-Philippe watch. It was in the Grand Master Chime model. Now does it make more sense, Angela? It was a Grandmaster Chime.
它在2016年以480万美元的价格售出。有史以来拍卖的最昂贵的腕表。我的意思是，我发现这很迷人，因为我心想，真的，一块手表卖了3100万美元。我不明白。它叫百达翡丽手表。它在Grand Master Chime型号里。现在更有意义了吗，安吉拉？它是一个Grandmaster Chime。
Somewhere there's someone fan. and their ears are bleeding because they're like, ladies, you have no idea what you're talking about. Yeah, we need to pay 31 million for the Grand Master Chime. I hid this watch up my ass. Oh, boy, that watch, I'd love to know how much that watch could go for an auction. But this shattered the record. The previous record was a Rolex that was once owned by Paul Newman, and it had sold for 17.7. I don't want to tell people that they're spending their money wrong, but I don't know.
某个地方有某个人粉丝。而他们的耳朵在流血，因为他们心想，女士们，你们根本不知道自己在说什么。是的，我们需要为Grand Master Chime支付3100万。我把这块表藏在我的屁股里。哦，天哪，那块表，我很想知道那块表在拍卖会上能卖多少钱。但这打破了记录。之前的记录是一块曾经属于保罗·纽曼的劳力士，它以1770万的价格售出。我不想告诉人们他们花钱花错了，但我不知道。
Do you want to know the most expensive diamonds? I mean, does Elizabeth have one? No, sorry. Elizabeth Taylor did not sell the most expensive diamond. The most expensive blue diamond ever sold in auction history was the Oppenheimer Blue, and it sold for $57.9 million. The most expensive diamond diamond was sold for $71.2 million. at an auction in Hong Kong, and it is a 59.6-carat pink star diamond. Wow.
你想知道最昂贵的钻石吗？我的意思是，伊丽莎白有一颗吗？不，抱歉。伊丽莎白·泰勒没有卖出最昂贵的钻石。拍卖史上售出的最昂贵的蓝钻是奥本海默蓝钻，它以5790万美元的价格售出。最昂贵的钻石钻石以7120万美元的价格售出。在香港的一次拍卖会上，它是一颗59.6克拉的粉红之星钻石。哇。
And it was the largest, flawless, fancy, vivid pink diamond ever graded by the Gemological Institute of America. What do you do with that? I don't know. What do you do with that? It would stress me out. I don't know what you do with it. I mean, I'm always like, you know, you have one lamp that's nice or than your other lamps and I'm always like to the kids, don't touch that lamp.
它是美国宝石学院分级的最大的、无瑕的、花式、鲜艳的粉红钻石。你用那个做什么？我不知道。你用那个做什么？它会让我感到压力。我不知道你用它做什么。我的意思是，我总是像，你知道，你有一盏灯比你的其他灯好，我总是对孩子们说，不要碰那盏灯。
Guys. You guys, stop touching the pink star diamond. Stop it. If you have to play with something, play with the Oppenheimer blue. Do not throw the frisbee near that diamond. Damn it. Stop it, guys. That's how my other diamond broke.
伙计们。你们这些家伙，停止触摸粉红之星钻石。停下。如果你必须玩什么，玩奥本海默蓝钻。不要把飞盘扔在那颗钻石附近。该死。停下，伙计们。我的另一颗钻石就是那样碎的。
Exactly. And no, you cannot wear my grandmaster chime to school. Finally, I'm going to tell you what I am assuming is the most. most expensive used tissue. What? That has ever been auctioned. I can't be sure. Who wants a used tissue?
完全正确。而且不，你不能戴着我的Grandmaster Chime去学校。最后，我要告诉你我假设是最昂贵的用过的纸巾。什么？曾经被拍卖过的。我不能确定。谁想要用过的纸巾？
Somebody did. Did Elvis blow his nose as an Elvis tissue? No, it belonged to Scarlett Johansson. What? She sold it for $2,050 on eBay. The story is that she had been on the Tonight Show with Jay Leno in 2008, and she had a cold. She said, Samuel L. Jackson gave me a cold. And she said, you know what?
有人想要。埃尔维斯擤鼻涕了吗，是埃尔维斯的纸巾吗？不，它属于斯嘉丽·约翰逊。什么？她在eBay上以2050美元的价格卖掉了它。故事是她在2008年参加了杰·雷诺的今夜秀，她感冒了。她说，塞缪尔·杰克逊传染了我感冒。她说，你知道吗？
I'm going to auction off my tissue for charity, and she did. Okay. All right. You know what I learned here? People bid crazy amounts of money on really random things. Yeah. Should we go to the bar? Should we get back to the episode and go to the bar?
我要为慈善拍卖我的纸巾，她确实这么做了。好的。好吧。你知道我在这里学到了什么吗？人们在非常随机的事情上出价疯狂的金额。是的。我们去酒吧吗？我们回到剧集去酒吧吗？
I guess so. Well, Jim and the warehouse fellas are having a great time at the bar. Jim's going to get another round. Yeah. He heads over to the bar. And who walks in? It's Roy. Roy Anderson.
我想是的。好吧，吉姆和仓库伙计们在酒吧玩得很开心。吉姆要再来一轮。是的。他走向酒吧。谁进来了？是罗伊。罗伊·安德森。
Oof. He's like Halbert. And Jim's like, and Roy's like, don't worry, I'm not going to hit you. So Jim and Roy end up having a rather friendly conversation over some beers. They're catching up on life. He's telling Roy about Pam. Yeah.
哎哟。他就像哈尔伯特。吉姆说，罗伊说，别担心，我不会打你的。所以吉姆和罗伊最终在喝啤酒时进行了一次相当友好的谈话。他们在叙旧。他告诉罗伊关于帕姆的事。是的。
He tells Roy Pam's at art school. And also, she's engaged. To me. And Roy's like, wow, okay. And then they kind of do like a, they don't quite shake hands. It's weird. It's like Roy holds his hand up over his shoulder and then Jim grabs it. They have some type of bro handshake moment.
他告诉罗伊帕姆在艺术学校。而且，她订婚了。和我。罗伊说，哇，好的。然后他们有点像，他们没有完全握手。很奇怪。就像罗伊把手举过肩膀，然后吉姆抓住了它。他们有某种兄弟握手的时刻。
I loved that. Jim even sort of doubles down and is like, oh yeah, she's having a great time at art school. She was out to like nine in the morning with her friends. And then Roy says, huh, you were a friend. And Jim is like, oh crap. Oh, crap. Like it kind of plants the seed of doubt in Jim's brain. Like it's Pam connecting with other people, the way she connected with me, what's going on at art school.
我喜欢那个。吉姆甚至有点加倍努力，说，哦，是的，她在艺术学校玩得很开心。她和她的朋友们一直待到早上九点。然后罗伊说，嗯，你是个朋友。吉姆说，哦，该死。哦，该死。就像它在吉姆的大脑里种下了怀疑的种子。就像帕姆以她与我联系的方式与其他人联系，艺术学校发生了什么。
So Jim Spirals, and he's like, I'm going to go see her. I'm going to go see her. I'm going to drive to New York. Yeah. I want you guys to know that there were some missing scenes in this Jim and Pam storyline. There were extra scenes because we did get some mail from people where they were like, wow, this one comment from Roy really made Jim Spiral. You know, why was he so insecure about their relationship?
所以吉姆螺旋式下降，他心想，我要去见她。我要去见她。我要开车去纽约。是的。我想让你们知道，在这个吉姆和帕姆的故事线中，有一些缺失的场景。有额外的场景，因为我们确实收到了一些人的邮件，他们说，哇，罗伊的这一句评论真的让吉姆螺旋式下降了。你知道，为什么他对他们的关系这么不安全？
Now, we know he's going to turn around. He's not actually going to drive to New York. going to turn around, but there's a lot more motivating this spiral than just Roy's comment. Yes, there was a whole storyline, you guys, between Jim and Pam. That would have started early in the episode and would have built to this moment. Yeah. So earlier, remember, Jim was on the phone and he got this voicemail from Pam where she's out with her friends. Well, what's missing is that there was a really cute bit where Jim and Pam are talking on the phone and they are talking about about the West Wing. Yes, and Jenna, it's so cute. They share that they watch it together on the
现在，我们知道他要回头了。他实际上不会开车去纽约。要回头了，但推动这个螺旋的不仅仅是罗伊的评论。是的，你们这些家伙，吉姆和帕姆之间有一个完整的故事线。那会在剧集早期开始，并会建立到这一刻。是的。所以早些时候，记得，吉姆在电话上，他收到了帕姆的这个语音留言，她和她的朋友们出去了。好吧，缺失的是有一个非常可爱的片段，吉姆和帕姆在电话上交谈，他们正在谈论关于白宫风云。是的，而且珍娜，太可爱了。他们分享说他们一起在
DVD. So like they both have to hit play at the same time. I thought that was so cute. I have done that with friends. So cute. This is old tech romance, guys. In the script, this scene goes on and Jim says, are we on for the next episode tonight? Pam says, you know what? Can we rain check it basically? You know, she says, I'm really tired. I think I'm just going to go to bed early. Yeah, she's had a big week at school. Yeah. So, you know, fine. But then later what happens is she leaves Jim a message where she says, oh my gosh, my friends,
DVD上观看它。所以就像他们都必须同时按下播放键。我觉得那太可爱了。我和朋友们这样做过。太可爱了。这是旧技术浪漫，伙计们。在剧本里，这个场景继续，吉姆说，我们今晚看下一集吗？帕姆说，你知道吗？我们可以改天吗？你知道，她说，我真的很累。我想我只是要早点睡觉。是的，她在学校度过了忙碌的一周。是的。所以，你知道，好吧。但后来发生的是她给吉姆留了一条信息，她说，哦，天哪，我的朋友们，
they're dragging me out. They convince me to go out. I'll call you later. Then Jim gets the butt dial from the bar, from the bar where she's having a great time. And then Pam leaves him a message explaining that she did not get home until eight in the morning. So she was too tired. to watch West Wing, but she went out with friends till eight in the morning. So that is really why Jim spirals for a second and is going to drive to New York. Yeah. That's why Roy's comment really took
他们拖我出去。他们说服我出去。我稍后再给你打电话。然后吉姆从酒吧收到了误拨，从酒吧，她在那里玩得很开心。然后帕姆给他留了一条信息，解释说她直到早上八点才回家。所以她太累了。不能看白宫风云，但她和朋友们出去玩到了早上八点。所以这就是为什么吉姆有一秒钟螺旋式下降并要开车去纽约。是的。这就是为什么罗伊的评论真的扎根了
root, you know, because he's like, well, wait a second. I kind of feel like she just blew me off for these people. I don't even know. Yeah. And we're just going to leave you hanging on that one, by the way. Jim drives back and, you know, we'll work this out in the next episode. Well, back at the auction, it's 614. Yeah. It's the deadline. Dwight looks over at Angela, and Angela purposefully looks to Andy. Dwight is crushed. She's made her choice. She's made her choice. Well, there was a scripted Angela talking head that didn't make it in. That would have gone right here. And Angela says, I'm not the type of person who breaks engagements. you should go talk to Pam.
，你知道，因为他心想，好吧，等等。我有点觉得她只是为了这些人把我打发了。我甚至不知道。是的。顺便说一句，我们要让你悬念在那一点上。吉姆开车回来，你知道，我们会在下一集解决这个问题。好吧，回到拍卖会，现在是6点14分。是的。是截止日期。德怀特看向安吉拉，安吉拉故意看向安迪。德怀特崩溃了。她做出了选择。她做出了选择。好吧，有一个剧本里的安吉拉访谈没有放进去。那会在这里。安吉拉说，我不是那种解除婚约的人。你应该去和帕姆谈谈。
Once again, Angela is going to throw Pam under the bus. Yeah. When it comes to questions about her personal life, she's like, wait, who can I distract with? Oh, yeah, Pam. Dwight is like, Phyllis. Phyllis, someone has let the air out of all of your tires. Come look. And Phyllis goes outside.
再一次，安吉拉要让帕姆背黑锅。是的。当涉及到关于她个人生活的问题时，她心想，等等，我可以分散谁的注意力？哦，是的，帕姆。德怀特说，菲利斯。菲利斯，有人把你所有轮胎的气都放了。来看看。菲利斯走到外面。
And yes, her tires are all flat. And Dwight's like, no, no, no, no, I just need an excuse to get you out here. And I love Phyllis's line. Like, why couldn't you have just said it? Why'd you have to do it? Yeah. But Dwight's like, what do I do now? What do I do now?
是的，她的轮胎都瘪了。德怀特说，不，不，不，不，我只是需要一个借口把你叫出来。我喜欢菲利斯的台词。就像，为什么你不能直接说出来？你为什么要这样做？是的。但德怀特说，我现在该怎么办？我现在该怎么办？
The ultimatum passed. And that's when Phyllis is like, well, I think you have your answer. It's the end, Dwight. That's what happens. You got to let it go. Yeah. Dwight is furious with Phyllis. But then he has this moment when he's by himself.
最后通牒过去了。那就是菲利斯说，好吧，我想你有了答案。结束了，德怀特。这就是发生的事情。你必须放手。是的。德怀特对菲利斯很生气。但他有一个他独自一人的时刻。
And he's like, you know, kind of like, how dare her? She's so selfish. Here she was just trying to help me. And then he sort of hears what he's just said. She was just trying to help him. That's what motivates him to go in and bid on her hug and drive the price up. Ultimately, it goes to Bob Vance. And Angela is so confused.
他心想，你知道，有点像，她怎么敢？她太自私了。她刚才只是想帮我。然后他听到了他刚才说的话。她只是想帮他。这就是激励他进去竞拍她的拥抱并推高价格的原因。最终，它归了鲍勃·万斯。安吉拉非常困惑。
She's like, why is Dwight bidding on a hug with Phyllis like so aggressively? It's his way of saying thank you, I guess. Yeah. Well, she's the big winner of the night. It goes for the most money because, as it turns out, Michael can't find the spring scene tickets. Can you believe it? Oh, what could have happened to them?
她心想，为什么德怀特竞拍菲利斯的拥抱这么激进？我想这是他表示感谢的方式。是的。好吧，她是当晚的大赢家。它卖出了最多的钱，因为，事实证明，迈克尔找不到斯普林斯汀的票了。你能相信吗？哦，它们可能发生了什么？
Where are they? He definitely had them all the time. He definitely had them. Even though we learned that, you know, they're not even touring right now. Well, there's a very sweet scene now between Michael and Holly, where Michael does admit that it's kind of a gray area, whether or not he had the Springsteen tickets. A lot about Michael is too good to be true, she says. Well, and you know how Jen Salada was always ruining takes by laughing on set? Yes, all the time, especially talking heads.
它们在哪里？他肯定一直都有它们。他肯定有它们。尽管我们了解到，你知道，它们现在甚至没有巡演。好吧，现在迈克尔和霍莉之间有一个非常甜蜜的场景，迈克尔确实承认，他是否有斯普林斯汀的票是一个灰色地带。关于迈克尔的很多事情都好得令人难以置信，她说。好吧，而且你知道珍·萨拉达总是因为在片场笑而毁掉拍摄吗？是的，一直都是，尤其是访谈。
Well, Jen told me that she totally ruined a take during this scene. She says the moment when Holly is trying to cover Michael's mouth and tell him, don't say it, don't say it. And then how Michael is sort of delighted by this, so he starts laughing and then Holly starts laughing. Jen said that it felt so real to her that she thought they had broke. So Jen started laughing and ultimately ruined the take. and Steve was like, why were you laughing? And she said, I thought you were breaking. And he said, no, we were just acting.
好吧，珍告诉我她在这一幕中完全毁掉了一次拍摄。她说当霍莉试图捂住迈克尔的嘴并告诉他，别说，别说。然后迈克尔是如何被这个逗乐的，所以他开始笑，然后霍莉开始笑。珍说这让她感觉太真实了，以至于她以为他们破功了。所以珍开始笑，最终毁掉了拍摄。而史蒂夫说，你为什么在笑？她说，我以为你破功了。他说，不，我们只是在演戏。
And then they all kind of laughed at that. But she said that moment made it onto the blooper reel. It did. I watched it. It's on Season 5 bloopers on YouTube. You can see Jen cracking up. The episode ends with a kiss. Michael and Holly kiss.
然后他们都因为那个笑了。但她说那一刻进入了花絮。确实。我看了。它在YouTube上的第五季花絮里。你可以看到珍笑得前仰后合。这一集以一个吻结束。迈克尔和霍莉接吻。
More than once. There's a little kiss than a bigger kiss. You guys, they're at work. Yeah. And David Wallace is there. He's watching from a distance. Mm-hmm. And this episode ends with him saying,
不止一次。有一个小吻，然后是一个更大的吻。伙计们，他们在工作。是的。大卫·华莱士在那里。他从远处看着。嗯。这一集以他说的话结束，
no, I did not know that Michael was dating Holly. He doesn't seem happy about it. Mm, yeah. He's not. I mean, look what happened when Michael dated Jan. Oh, my gosh. But David, what you don't know is that these guys are soulmates. Ugh.
不，我不知道迈克尔在和霍莉约会。他看起来不太高兴。嗯，是的。他不是。我的意思是，看看迈克尔和简约会时发生了什么。哦，天哪。但是大卫，你不知道的是这些人是灵魂伴侣。呃。
Ah! But this is going to cause some problems for this couple going forward. We have a lot of couples in crisis. Yeah. Season five. Dwayangela, Jam, Molly, or Heichel. What are we calling them? Heichel?
啊！但这会导致这对情侣在未来出现一些问题。我们有很多情侣处于危机中。是的。第五季。德怀特安吉拉，吉姆帕姆，霍莉迈克尔。我们叫他们什么？Heichel？
Holly and Michael? Yeah. They're either Molly or Heichael. Hegel. Season five, shaking it up, guys. Shagging it up. Well, there you have it. That's Crime Aid.
霍莉和迈克尔？是的。他们要么是Molly，要么是Heichael。Hegel。第五季，动摇它，伙计们。动摇它。好吧，这就是了。这就是犯罪援助。
I certainly learned a lot this episode. For example, Groupon doing crazy service. Yeah, very crazy surveys, and we know the most expensive used tissue ever sold at auction that I could find. Mm-hmm. There could be more. There could be more, but as far as I could find, that record goes to Scarlett Johansson. Congratulations, Scarlett. And in Crime Aid, the most expensive item sold goes to Phyllis. Way to go, Phyllis. Way to go, Phyllis. I'd take that hug.
我这一集确实学到了很多。例如，Groupon做疯狂的服务。是的，非常疯狂的调查，我们知道拍卖会上售出的最昂贵的用过的纸巾，我能找到的。嗯。可能还有更多。可能还有更多，但就我所能找到的，那个记录属于斯嘉丽·约翰逊。恭喜你，斯嘉丽。而在犯罪援助中，售出的最昂贵的物品归菲利斯所有。干得好，菲利斯。干得好，菲利斯。我会接受那个拥抱。
It's a good hug. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. We'll see you next week. We hope you have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
这是一个好拥抱。好了，伙计们。我们下周见。我们下周见。我们希望你们过得愉快。感谢收听办公室女士的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。办公室女士是Odyssey的呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Your Music. Creed Braden. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Your Music的Ruppertree。克里德·布拉顿。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。